[Music]
welcome
to season two of a bit of optimism
i'm thrilled to be back and to kick off
the new season
i decided to invite adam grant adam is
an organizational psychologist
a new york times best-selling author and
one of the top
rated professors at the wharton school
he's also
the yin tamayang he has a breadth of
knowledge
that few others can even come close it's
kind of unbelievable
so instead of talking about something
specific we decided to talk
a little bit about everything and it was
really interesting
this is a bit of optimism
[Music]
i invited you to be here because i love
you because i love your work and i love
you and i love your perspective on the
world
when i was thinking about what i wanted
to talk to you about you know there's so
many things that you've done that i find
interesting
that i actually in the end decided not
to pick a subject
you know you you use the word love and i
have to say that's a strong word i don't
know if i love you but i do like you a
lot
and i find you endlessly fascinating
[Laughter]
i love your work that's much better by
the way if if somebody has a choice
between loving me and loving my work i
would rather they love my work and like
me than vice versa yes that's true
but that's a whole different podcast
yes it is so how am i i am uh i'm good
and you yeah i'm fine i find these times
fascinating i like disruption
you're an alien no you know dr carso's
work
dr cars james cars in his explanation of
finite mindedness and infinite
mindedness
tells how a finite-minded perspective
all of the thinking has done in the past
so that's why finite-minded fears
surprises and fears
uncertainty because they don't like
those things which is why there's so
much
preparing so athletes are constantly
practicing practicing practicing
practicing
so that there are no surprises and you
know in the military they train and
train and train and train and train
so there are no surprises and you hear
them say this all the time they say i
didn't have to think
i just relied on my training i didn't
have to think it was just the muscle
memory
and so problems happen when there has to
be new thinking
in the moment an infinite minded
perspective
is embracing uncertainty and surprises
the thinking begins now
you throw out all the old stuff because
it's irrelevant
and new thinking begins and so the
reason i like disruption
is because it forces new thinking i
think that's the most compelling
explanation i've ever heard for your
alien mind and the way it works
and you know but but simon it actually
it highlights one of the things that
i've learned from you
even before we met when i was watching
your your ted talk and then some of your
other videos
i remember watching you think out loud
and thinking i wish i had the courage
and the comfort to do that
and then of course my next thought was
well maybe i could learn to do that
and i will never do that as as well as
you do but it's been an aspiration for
me
and i think it's um it's something we
need more
great thinkers to do because otherwise
it it almost seems like
it seems like a book or an idea or a
talk
kind of emerges fully formed from zeus
and we never get to see the stumbles
and the contradictions and you know sort
of the the big gaps in our thinking
and so i love the way that you're you're
actually willing to put your thinking
out there
because it it sort of normalizes this
idea that
you know you you may have a lot of good
ideas but not all of them are are going
to stand
the test of rigor and thank you that's
very nice of you to say and that's very
true
and you can actually watch the
progression of a thought too
it's like when i first started publicly
talking about finite infinite games
it was a rough and tumble talk but it's
online i did one
for google very early and i like cringe
at some of the things i've said but
there it is it's on youtube
and it's not a fully formed idea i don't
know where it comes from
i mean look people ask me how do you
become a public speaker and you know i
always tell them i cheat
and i do two things which is i only talk
about things i
care about i only talk about things i
understand
that doesn't mean i have to know all the
details
but i have enough of a framework that i
can actually have a conversation about
whatever it is i'm
talking about it and it's like two
people sitting at dinner it's like we're
constantly having conversations about
things we don't understand we talk about
politics we talk about kovid
yet none of us are scientists and none
of us live in washington
and yet we all talk as if we know all
the details and some of it's quite
compelling
and some of us actually have some really
interesting ideas to contribute to those
things
so you know i know enough to be
dangerous in whatever i'm talking about
and that's it really and i think a
little bit of courage
the first time i ever talked about
finite infinite games publicly i was
inspired by seth godin
he and i were speaking at the same
conference i was hired to speak about
leaders eat last
which is the book that was out at the
time he went before me
and he gave this wonderful speech about
courage and taking risks and doing
dangerous things
in his wonderful way that he talks about
these things and literally he came off
the stage and i went up next
and i said to the audience i'm supposed
to talk about
this thing but would you like me to talk
about something that i've been thinking
about but i've never talked about
publicly
and they all clapped so i went all right
this could suck here we go
and it was really that and the audience
is so supportive
i think there's so many things i want to
ask you about from that and
uh a few reactions as well but the first
thing is
i always thought that a talk had to be
the final draft
and you you said you know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna not only
show you my first draft i'm gonna write
my first draft on stage
and the only other person i know who at
least is willing to admit to doing that
is trevor noah
i remember going into the the writer's
room at the daily show and
asking him you know what his process was
and he said well you know the hardest
thing about doing the daily show for me
is when i do when i do stand up i go in
with a bunch of prepared material
but i usually end up thinking i have a
you know more entertaining
thought while i'm on stage than what i
plan and i end up throwing out all my
material and
inventing 90 of it on the spot and i
don't really have the freedom to do that
in front of a camera
and i guess you know i i'm curious about
when
when you've regretted uh writing your
draft on stage
and when it's actually served you well
because i imagine there are some times
where it makes sense to do it and there
are situations where
you might want to be a little more
polished yeah
that's true so back when i was when i
was in marketing and advertising and
worked for big companies
i remember watching these really
powerful speakers on stage and i would
buy tickets and go to these conferences
and see people like seth godin
you know giving talks and i was just
blown away by how
natural and spontaneous they were and i
actually
had the false belief i assumed that they
were speaking extemporaneously
because that's how good they were and so
i thought whoa that's a high standard
and so i literally thought that's the
standard i have to live up to
and so i practiced to do that
only years later to discover that they
all rehearse and practice and memorize
and i didn't know that i i because it
looked so natural
i thought that was the standard i had to
learn so i learned the wrong thing
but it also happened when i was i
remember i would give formal business
presentations with my powerpoint
and i was having more ideas that were
ahead of my powerpoint and i kept going
ahead of my slides or
saying things that were more interesting
than my slides and having thoughts that
had dynamism that wasn't on the slides
and the slides kept tripping me up
and so one day i thought just let's bag
the slides because they keep getting in
the way
and so it wasn't that i just decided to
do it you know i had these prepared
remarks
and i i realized that i was comfortable
enough i got comfortable enough
speaking beyond the slides and then just
trusted that i could do it without them
so i got rid of the safety blanket
and i think that's all it is i think
people cling to the safety blanket
it's like i remember when i was learning
to swim you know i had uh
i don't know what you call them in
america i think they're called floaties
they call them armbands
where i grew up and so i had floaties on
and they were filled with there and i'd
learned to swim and my mother would let
a little air out as i was getting better
at something and i was at the point
where
they had no air in them they were
completely deflated
and my mother's like you don't need them
anymore and i insisted on wearing them
and i think that's the powerpoint for
most people you don't need them you're
not using it
it makes you feel better when you jump
in the pool i think that's a it's a
great metaphor
simon i want to actually circle back to
something you alluded to
adam it's so nice to be on your podcast
you know old habits die hard right no no
but i
i feel like this is a rare opportunity
where i don't have a script for what i
want to learn
right i get to react to what i'm hearing
right you know in real time which is
which is always fun
but you you alluded to something that i
think is really fascinating and
it's it's actually something i've
wondered about you on and off but i
don't think i've ever
i don't think i've ever thought to ask
you about it so you call yourself an
optimist
yes yes i think you still consider
yourself is it still your identity it is
okay and yet you were describing to me
something that i associate much more
with defensive pessimism
have you have you come across that work
in psychology at all no tell me about it
okay so uh there's the psychologist
julie norham who i think in part in
reaction to
the abundance of conversation about how
we all need to be positive and cheery
and optimistic
uh she studied this this strategy that
that i
recognized in myself and i never know
where i stand on the spectrum because i
identify with both sides of it but the
gist is think back to when you're in
school
and you're preparing for a big test the
the strategic optimists would create
this mental picture of
just mastering the material and that
image would energize you you'd study
hard and you aced the test
the defensive pessimist has a slightly
different emotional experience
which is about a week before the exam
you wake up in the middle of the night
in a cold sweat that you did so badly on
the test
you not only failed but your instructor
took away points on all your previous
exams
because there's no way you could earn
those right and that that panic
that sends you into a frenzy of you know
a motivation
you prepare hard and you actually
perform every bit as well as the
optimist does
and when you're when you actually track
strategic optimists and defensive
pessimists they are equally effective
provided that a few things are true
number one the defensive pessimists have
to be nervous
far enough in advance that their anxiety
can motivate them to prepare
and then number two you have to be
careful not to make them too happy
early on because then they get
complacent and they don't do all this
this prep work
which is hilarious right it's like okay
if you're a defensive pessimist you
either get to be
anxious up front and successful or you
can be happy
and vomit yeah so i i was interested one
in your reaction to that but two
the level of preparation you're
describing it sounds to me like you have
a little bit of defensive pessimism in
you
despite being an optimist yeah so i
don't want to go down the semantic
rabbit hole here
but based on her definitions sure i'm
absolutely
the of pessimists i mean you described
my behavior yes
though both of those seem like
pejorative terms so
nobody wants to be described as you know
a defensive like try call try calling
your spouse a defensive pessimist in an
argument see how that goes
um you know the
the way i define optimism is not my my
work process
which sounds more like defensive
pessimism the way i define optimism is
is i generally believe the future is
bright what i choose to do
is focus on that there was a a a
scientist in england like i could
try to remember her name see this is
where i adore you
and where you're so good and i have you
know and we'll talk about
worthy rivalry later but this is where
you are so
good is your rigor and your ability to
remember
every study every scientist the details
is fantastic i have like these general
recollections about what the what the
work is but there's a scientist in
england that i met
but i can't remember her name well tell
me about her work maybe i'll know it
um she was doing work on optimism and
she'd actually come up with a test
on are you an optimist and where are you
on the optimism spectrum
and so it was arranged for me to go and
like take her test
and i was petrified because here i am
with the self-definition of being an
optimist
what if she tells me that i'm like below
average based on her assessment
so i had this horrible fear of taking
her test i didn't want to take it
you know if you don't go to the doctor
you're not sick you know same idea
so anyway i went and took this test and
the way that she
tested for optimism was how bad news
affected you
so there was a baseline where she gave
you all of these scenarios and
your reaction to them and then she added
some bad news to the
section and then did these follow-ups
and most people
they're like let's say i mean pick a
situation
you know you're going to work your boss
is in a really bad mood
or something horrible has happened in
the world you know and she gets some
pretty dark stuff like
cancer and stuff like that how's your
day gonna go some stuff like that and
and once you're given the bad news your
baseline goes down that's sort of i
think that's the gist
of how she did it anyway what it turned
out was
even in the face of bad news i
either stayed the same or went up in
what i believe the future would be
that's how i choose to define optimism i
like it well that
that tracks with the with the marty
seligman definition
of optimism which is a style of
explaining the events in your life
right and processing them in a certain
way and saying look just because
something went horribly wrong
doesn't mean it's my fault right it's
not necessarily personal it doesn't mean
it's going to ruin every part of my life
it might not be pervasive
and it might not be this bad forever so
it's not totally permanent
and what i've always loved about that
that way of thinking about optimism as a
style of processing events in your life
is that means we can learn it and teach
it and so what it says to me is
even if your name is simon sinek right
you're literally you're literally acidic
i know and even if you you imagine the
worst case scenario and then try to
prevent it
right you can teach yourself to process
events in such a way that you
don't always just see the worst in them
yeah which is kind of kind of liberating
and optimism is not pollyanna-ish either
people come to me
like you're grumpy i'm like yes i'm
grumpy i'm
very very cynical i'm often judgmental
you know it's like none of those have
any bearing
on the fact that i still believe the
future's bright
well you're you're a disagreeable
optimist i love it
i am how do you define yourself
i've never known what to do on that you
know on that axis because
i feel like somebody called me an
informed optimist once and i liked that
because it it signaled not pollyanna
but i i think you're right we shouldn't
associate optimism with with being a
pollyanna in fact
there was a teresa mobile study years
ago
where she did this what early 80s
so basically what she did was she gave
sorry i'm doing it right now
i know i love you must be so good i'm a
little disappointed you didn't tell me
the exact date but we'll we'll let it go
you know i i'm pretty sure it was 82.
um the paper is titled brilliant but
cruel but i'm thinking it might be 83
anyway
so what teresa did was she gave people
book reviews
and the content was identical across the
different conditions in the experiment
so you know the the book was evaluated
as you know as
as looking into these themes and all she
did was she varied the tone
and sometimes the reviewer was was
overall enthusiastic about the book and
other times
the reviewer was critical and the
critical reviewer was judged as smarter
even though the sophistication of
analysis was the same
and i thought that was such a problem
and i i see this by the way when when i
mentor doctoral students
is you know right around year two the
only thing they can ever do when they
read a paper is tear it apart
and i'm thinking okay some of the
smartest people in the world in this
field
wrote this paper it got through the
standards of our top journal and you a
second year phd
student think it's garbage what's going
on here i think we have a culture
where you learn that you signal your
intelligence by tearing other people's
work apart
and i think it often takes much greater
intelligence to
build an idea than it does to destroy it
oh that's so good that's so interesting
i wonder if it's um did the paper
comment on where that what they believe
the
the root is of that response i think the
the the gist of theresa's analysis we
should ask her but as i remember it
she said basically if you're critical
you're seen as having higher standards
you're more discerning
and if you're positive that signaled
that you were easier to impress
or too gullible interesting and i wonder
if there's also insecurity in there as
well which is
i have to prove that i know something
and to simply agree
i don't get an opportunity i don't get
any mic time you know
that's right yeah i'm offering nothing
great analysis you know
[Music]
it's as opposed to the ability to sort
of
yeah it makes logical sense it is
disheartening though isn't it
that the way that we perceive people as
smart as if they're critical
i mean turn on the freaking television
all we have is a culture of
blind criticism to the point where we've
we've even
lost the interest of asking the person
or following up we lodge our criticisms
and our analysis
before we even just say hey what did you
mean by that can you clarify your point
i don't understand do you know of any
research of people in leadership
positions who express
doubt or uncertainty about their own
intelligence in other words i don't
understand
yeah there's a whole body of research on
this by brad owens and his colleagues
so they study it in terms of leadership
humility and one of their most
interesting findings is you normally
think you know a leader on the extreme
end of humility
is basically going to be too
self-deprecating and if they go to the
opposite extreme then they're going to
be a narcissist
well it turns out those two axes are
independent and so there's a group of
leaders that brad calls
humble narcissists which sounds like an
oxymoron but they actually are rated as
the most effective leaders by their
teams
they also end up having the most
productive and creative teams and this
has been shown in both the us and china
and i think it's a little bit of a
misnomer to call a leader a humble
narcissist
i think what we're really talking about
is confident humility and
as you know it takes tremendous
confidence to say i don't know
right to recognize that you are capable
enough that you've established enough
credibility
you know that you can admit when you're
uninformed or when your knowledge is
incomplete
and so i think in his data what he would
tell you is
that when leaders are able to do that
right when they're able to say you know
what
we're in the middle of a pandemic i have
no idea
how we should be evolving our strategy
and i'm not sure if we should be
reimagining our products or our services
but i am confident that i have an
amazing team around me and that together
we can figure this out
that that's what really builds trust and
credibility and leadership is that the
kind of thing you were driving at
yeah that's 100 what i was driving at
because some of the best leaders i've
met
and i love it when senior senior leaders
take somebody
that they respect and put them in charge
of something that they have no
experience in
and the good leaders who in those
positions and i've had the opportunity
to meet some of them
you know i show up on the third or you
know their third week of work
i'm like hey how's it going they're like
dude i don't know anything
[Laughter]
and and they're very open about it they
they show up on their first day and they
say to their teams
hey guys uh i don't know anything you've
been doing this for years
i don't i haven't um i'm gonna
ask you a ton of questions i'm gonna
lean on you i'm gonna try and learn as
much as i can
but i'm here to give you the space you
need in the top cover you need to go off
and do your
thing i'm here to look after you and it
forces
what is considered good basic leadership
behavior the problem is i think people
when you know too much
you know when you actually do know how
to do somebody else's job better than
they do because that's what got you
promoted
you know you don't actually become that
leader that you need to be
you end up becoming the manager not
because you're a bad person or anything
you just
you just know too much and there's
something to be said for ignorance
and it goes back to what we're saying
before which is embracing uncertainty
and surprise
you know like i know nothing this is
exciting
yeah that's such a cool reaction i wish
that was the default response right when
when leaders realize they're in over
their head to say
this is a learning opportunity and that
of course reminds me of another study uh
which is an elena botello study
uh looking at career catapults and
the the question here is why do some
people fast-track to the ceo
position or why do they end up on an
accelerated trajectory to the c-suite
and it turns out if you break down
people's career experiences
there's usually something that seems
like a counterproductive situation that
helped them got there so
for some people it's actually moving
laterally or backward instead of up
because it allowed them to learn in
other cases though it's having to clean
up a big mess
and getting responsibility that's way
above your level of experience which of
course is where you really get
challenged and stretched
and i think it would be incredibly
exciting if more leaders were willing to
take on those kinds of risks
and say you know what let me try to run
a function that i have
no expertise in whatsoever because
that's that's what i'm going to grow
yeah i gave a talk to some top surgeons
at a top
hospital in the country and they kept
going on and on about how
we're the top surgeons were the top
surgeons you know and all of this stuff
i said yeah but i don't i actually
wouldn't trust you with my surgery
and they all sort of like looked at me i
guess i said because my fear would be
that on some arbitrary ranking and it's
usually deaths
right for our surgeons it's how many
people have you killed on the operating
table
that people once they're labeled top
that they have the fewer deaths than
other surgeons
they will take easier cases for fear
of upsetting their their rankings
whereas
another surgeon may take the most
difficult cases
which means more people are going to die
so
is the top surgeon the best surgeon or
is the top surgeon the one who's taking
all the easier cases that he can ensure
he's going to have success so that he
doesn't have another death that will
ruin his record
because he becomes more obsessed with
his ranking than actually helping people
survive
whereas the one who says this is
impossible i'll give it a try
and it failed i want that person that's
fascinating so i think some of these
rankings
are very very dangerous because we don't
know the motivation
and the question is is what's the
motivation is the motivation the ranking
or is the motivation the work
yeah oh this is so interesting so a
couple data points that might speak to
that and i i'm curious to hear your
interpretation of them the first one
is there's a boris grossberg study of
star security analysts on wall street
and a general pattern is when you become
a superstar in the investing world
you immediately assume that the grass
has got to be green or somewhere else
and now you're worth more and so you get
poached by another firm
and boris finds that it takes on average
five years to recover your star status
once you leave for a new firm unless you
take your team with you
in which case there is no drop in your
performance and so part of what i see
there is if we take your surgeon analogy
you've got these surgeons who think
they're individual geniuses they
underestimate how dependent they are on
the people around
them to be successful and then they
basically failed to reconstruct
the collaborative environment the
routines the complementary strengths
to offset their weaknesses that made
them great in the first place
and so i wonder if if there's something
we can do to help people who
think that they're individual geniuses
recognize that they're much more
interdependent than they are
independent in fact i wonder if we could
have a declaration of interdependence
not just a declaration of independence
yeah yeah this is something i've talked
about for a while which is
our country has over-indexed on rugged
individualism you know
that it's not all about the me and the
self and the self-help and the
like how do i get ahead and you know
like we have an entire section of the
bookshop called self-help we have no
section of the bookshop called help
others
and you're right you know no single
human being has ever achieved anything
by themselves
even if it was just their mom saying you
can do this
you know there's always someone a
relationship that believes in us
and i completely agree and i think this
goes to humility
bob gaylor who's the fifth chief master
sergeant of the air force
has my favorite definition of humility
he said don't confuse humility with
meekness
his humility is being open to the ideas
of others
which i absolutely love i like that a
lot
and so if i if i overlay that on the
brad owens work we were talking about
he would break humility down into into
three buckets
the first one is learning from others
which is exactly what that quote is
highlighting
the second is appreciating other
strengths which you could probably argue
is
a precursor to learning from others and
then the the third
is recognizing your own fallibility at
some level
and realizing i don't have all the
answers and i think the meekness part of
it is
is the part that so many people get
wrong one day i was curious i looked up
the latin root of the word
humility and it turns out it comes from
basically from the earth
is the latin root so it's about being
grounded right it's not saying
i can't do this and lacking self-esteem
it's saying you know what i may have
strengths but i have weaknesses too
i'm imperfect and because i might make
mistakes and i'm human
i need to learn from other people yeah
they're not mutually they're not
mutually exclusive ideas
i mean we know people with huge egos
that are very humble and to your point
like they know they're good they think
they're good
they're ambitious and yet to all those
definitions from brad owens
they're open to the ideas of others they
respect others and they're very open
about what they know and what they don't
know
and where they need help there's a case
to be made i think that steve jobs even
evolved in that direction
right if if you look at what he was like
when he basically got forced out of his
own company
and then you compare that with the steve
jobs who came back to apple
right and was willing to say you know
what i'm wrong i screwed up and
we're gonna try to fix things and make
him better i don't know that i would say
he was
he was ever humble but he was he was
more humble than he had been
and i don't think any of the narcissism
went away either right he he still
thought he had extraordinary ideas and
believed that he could run a company
that was going to change the world
but his openness to learning from other
people his willingness to say
you know what the most important product
that i ever created was not you know the
mac
or the iphone it was the team that made
the mac
and the team that built the iphone right
there is a tremendous amount of humility
in that that recognition that
he could not have done it without that
group of people and what most people
don't know about him
is that he invented none of the products
that apple ever made
zero a total of zero but he pushed
people to make those products better
well and i also heard once in a talk
that he had a hell of a why
so elizabeth gilbert when she gave her
ted talk i found that
very insightful and was also personally
very helpful to me when i
wrote my sophomore book when i wrote
leaders eat last
because everybody kept saying how are
you going to write a book as popular as
start with why or how are you going to
give a second ted talk that's going to
be as
better than the start with white ted
talk and the answer was
i'm not like that was an accident i
can't
reproduce it right i won the lottery
once i can't strategically win the
lottery again
but she gave this wonderful ted talk
about the concept of genius
where back in the pre-renaissance genius
was this damon the spirit that lived in
the walls
and when you did well people said you
had your genius ah
great book adam you had your genius and
if you screwed up or something went
badly
oh i guess your genius wasn't with you
but somewhere in the renaissance we
started to confuse having your genus
with being the genius
and now if you do something great you
are the genius and now there's this
unbelievable fear that you're going to
fall off the mantle
and i found that so peaceful you know
that i'm not fully responsible
for the work that i do that there's this
whatever you call it damon in the walls
or
matt damon lives on my walls or or
or inspiration or whatever you want to
call it it's just this calm
that i'll do my best work and if it's
with me
then it'll be well received and if it's
not with me
it won't and i'll just try again next
time and i really like that i really
loved what she
talked about i like the way you just
reframed that because
i i also i found liz's talk riveting i
especially love the part where she
talked about how
passion waxes and wanes but curiosity
always stays with us
and i've i've tried to apply that to my
creative projects ever since
i was on the fence about this genius
idea because
i felt like yes in in some ways it's
it's freeing but
there are other ways where i think we'll
i don't have any control this is
horrible
i'm going to do my best work and it
still might be a total dud
and i think your your point to say i'm
still going to do my best work
but that's not enough for it to have the
impact i want it to have
is probably a i guess you're more
buddhist than i am is is one way to put
this
and more more more accepting of the you
know the mix of internal and external
forces that affect our lives
um i think you're giving me too much
credit um
i was at a luncheon and i'm very bad at
these things because i'm i'm an
introvert and i don't like talking to
strangers and so
i usually bring somebody with me to
these things so that i can talk to
somebody
but i happen to have gone to this one
alone so i of course was talking to
nobody you know the hosts came and
introduced themselves and then
disappeared
and so there was a buffet of course i
made my way to the buffet by myself
and i happened to be standing next to a
guy as we made our way down the buffet
together you know shoulder to shoulder
and one of us said how are you or have
you been here before or whatever it was
and we get to talking
and we got along so we decided to sit
next to each other it turns out it was
bas lerman the director
and the way he described his work sums
it up beautifully for me which is
exactly how i like to approach mine as
well which is he said when he's working
on a project
he treats it like it's his child like he
puts everything
all of his energy into this thing so it
can be the best thing that it can be
and then when it's done he puts it out
into the world and it goes off and it
lives a life of its own
and he moves on to the next project and
he says people come up to be like oh my
god
i love moulin rouge and he'll say oh
how is he i haven't talked to him in
ages
say hi for me the next time you see him
you know
and i love that that our responsibility
folks like you and me
are to do our best put the work out and
then move on like
i have no interest in giving to start
with why talk anymore because
it's old work like i love it i'm proud
of it
i still believe in it i live my life by
it but i'm interested in new things
and i love the fact that i've i don't
try and push it in any direction
where i thought it would go it went
other places and i love just watching it
like a proud parent
go off and do its thing and i've tried
to do that with all my work
you put it out there and you just sort
of watch it go do its thing and if it
ends up in drug rehab
well then you know i'll i'll be
supportive and visit every saturday you
know
simon that that metaphor number one is
beautiful number two
it captures perfectly how i felt every
time
i see somebody write a nonfiction sequel
which is to say
you you're still too attached to this
idea you were supposed to
let people run with it the whole point
of a book is that
people hopefully it either starts new
conversations
or it revives old conversations and
it really gets people thinking and you
know the idea of
of saying well now i have to do the
follow-up as opposed to
going and giving birth to something new
to me was was always a waste of
somebody's
creativity and and time it's like my
first child is so magical i'm gonna try
and have another one just like the first
one
yeah why would you clone them it
completely misses the point
exactly i don't i don't want to clone
like i want to bring something new into
the world every time
but you know it's the devil you know
right like that was so successful
if i do a follow-up it'll have great
success which sometimes is true
but i think that goes back to whether
it's good work or whether it's popular
work there's a lot of bad work that's
popular and there's a good a lot of good
work that's not
and sometimes you hope the star is a
line and they go together but
but not always yeah there's a book that
i just bought but haven't read yet
called survival of the fittest by brian
hare and vanessa woods
it basically takes on that we've
misinterpreted darwin that when he said
fittest he doesn't necessarily mean
strongest
yeah amongst social animals it's
sociability it's cooperation
that it's the ability to take care of
the tribe and take care of the
group that is more likely to ensure your
survival
so we misinterpret it again in that
rugged individualism sort of like we
read the word
it's not that darwin got it wrong it's
the we got the darwin wrong but anyway
so it makes this case
you made as well they do it from a
biological standpoint they do it from a
biological
evolutionary standpoint well what i
think is so interesting about that is
you know there was this this idea that
got popular in the 60s that you're
familiar with called group selection
where you know the the traits that made
a group successful the thought was
you know might be important and that you
know even if you had a
you know a skill or a trait that was
sort of maladaptive individually if it
helped the group
and if the group was full of those
people you know they would be better off
at some level
and it got just eviscerated and
it's now making a renaissance yeah and
they're um evolutionary thinkers like
david sloane wilson who have
actually really put some teeth in the
idea and said look you know it's
actually possible
for a group to be fitter than other
groups and you know therefore to
outlast and you know propagate its its
genes and the funniest thing is
darwin actually knew this he wrote about
it he wrote that a a tribe of altruistic
people
would actually out survive a tribe of
selfish people because the altruistic
people would put the group first
and the group would therefore be able to
to live and it's so interesting that
we've largely ignored that
in our explanations of what it takes to
be the fittest yeah
why do we not recognize that the most
generous people
are often the ones who are most valued
by the group and therefore most likely
to survive and there's great data on
this which is that hierarchy is not a
bad thing and
we're naturally hierarchical animals
because we have to be our survival
depends on it
and it's sort of like the quote unquote
history of leadership you know
we lived in tribes no bigger than about
150.
there was an inherent problem these
austere times food is harder to come by
we're all hungry some hunters bring back
some food
we all rush in to eat and if you're
lucky enough to be built like a
linebacker you can shove your way to the
front of the line
but if you're the quote unquote creative
one of the family you're going to get an
elbow in the face
and this is a bad system because the
odds are
if you punch me in the face this
afternoon i'm probably not going to wake
you and alert you to danger
so we evolved into these hierarchical
animals we're constantly assessing and
judging each other
all the time who's alpha and we give
preferential treatment to our alphas
so in this case we know who our alphas
are in the in the tribe
we voluntarily step back our alphas are
given the opportunity to eat first
we're guaranteed food and we don't get
an elbow in the face
and this persists to this modern day
there's not a single person on the
planet
that is morally offended by the perks
that our alphas get for example
no one is morally offended that somebody
more senior in the company
gets a higher salary zero people are we
might think they're completely useless
at their job
but nobody's morally offended by the
fact that they're given more because
they're
further up in the hierarchy and there's
all kinds of other perks
you know for example if you're a senior
and you left your coat in the other room
someone will go get your coat for you if
you're junior and you left your coat in
the other room
you get your own coat right it's just
these are the perks that come with
moving up the hierarchy however the
group wasn't stupid
which is we don't give these perks away
for free there's an expectation
a deep seated social contract that if
danger threatens the tribe
the person who's actually smarter
actually stronger actually better fed
is going to be the one to rush towards
the danger to protect us
that's why we gave you first choice of
meat and first choice of mate
and where we get morally offended is
when
our leaders don't live up to that deep
social contract so when we know that
there's a
ceo who would sooner lay off people to
protect their bonus
then sacrifice their bonus to protect
their people that's what morally offends
us it's not their pay
it's whether they're willing to live up
to the deep-seated social contract
now the one part i rarely talk about
which is in that same research
when they go back and they've discovered
anthropological digs of tribes and you
know it's 150 people it's it's pretty
spread out all the different hudson
families
what they've been able to find is that
they can tell the quality of meat that
everybody's eating because they can tell
from the bones
and what they find is that the good
quality meat is actually distributed
so even though the alpha has the
opportunity to eat first
that alpha chose to share the best cuts
of meat with the rest of the tribe
so interesting that's what made homo
sapien
thrive which is we were cooperative we
looked after each other and our alphas
like a parent took particular care to
take care of the tribe
well that that forces us to really
rethink what it means
to be an alpha right and what it takes
to become an alpha i'm thinking one of
the
one of my favorite frameworks in
psychology is is to say look you know if
you think about what it takes to get
alpha status what most of us do is we
think well you know the alpha male or
alpha female
is the most dominant but dominance is
only one path to status right there's
another path that's called prestige
which is basically saying look i'm going
to earn the respect to the people around
me
not by intimidating them not by being
tougher or stronger than them
but by helping them by trying to make
them better
by you know really living the values of
the group and i think we get ourselves
into trouble when we we take you know
some degree of confidence as a proxy for
competence
when we assume that the people who are
most dominant are then going to use
their dominance
to elevate the group as opposed to just
to elevate themselves
and you know it's interesting that you
mentioned the the the firing and
downsizing theme because
the the research on this is so clear
there's a there's actually a paper in
one of our top management journals
called dumb and dumber
which compares companies that downsize
and let go of people to companies in
similarly difficult financial positions
but that either delay the firings as
long as possible they may go to
furloughs or
pay cuts or even you know a four day
work week for everyone
they actually perform better right and
some of that is is because
they're able to hang on to talent that
they didn't realize they needed
some of that is because they have less
survivor skill in the people that stay
and also less survivors anxiety and it
has been so short-sighted
as i've watched ceos who immediately
said well we're gonna have to lay off
half our workforce in the past six
months
i look at that and say do you not
realize the moment you do that
the people who are your your biggest
superstars are gonna
are gonna think to themselves well you
know what writing's on the wall i might
be next
and they're gonna jump ship and now
you've just shot yourself in the foot
but this is part of the problem it goes
to everything you said before
which is you know to come into the room
and [ __ ] on everybody else's work
makes you look smarter to come in and
fire everybody
makes you look like you're the
turnaround person you know like i came
and i made it i had the turn around it's
like well how'd you do that and how did
it do
the years after you left you know and
there's not a permanence to these
decisions but rather a temporariness to
these decisions
because the entire incentive structure
only rewards
the temporary success and i
unfortunately am
you know i think it's hard to teach an
old dog new tricks especially when
what got these people to these extreme
statuses is not a tenable
strategy for a company to survive in the
long term i think we just have to wait
for that generation to die off
and replace them with with new thinking
well that is the max planck theory of
of change in science right the the
paraphrase is that science progresses
one funeral at a time which
is so sad but but i understand it i
understand it like
if i've been doing one thing my whole
career and it's done me really well
and everybody says you have to change
like i have no evidence
in my entire career to show me that i
should change if this one note
has served me very well and despite the
fact that now the internet's a thing
where when i started it didn't exist
and i have to completely reinvent how i
imagined business for example
i still refuse to do it well okay so two
two additional data points that uh that
i i just i can't resist
one is damon santola uh he's one of the
the most interesting sociologists of
social networks
has a book coming out called change
where he shows that
influencers are actually overestimated
in their ability to shift other people's
behaviors and beliefs when it comes to
spreading a you know a product or
an idea fine but if you want to create
lasting or deep-seated change
he finds that the influencers are the
slowest to change because they're the
ones who are
pretty content with the status quo and
so they're the least likely to adopt
whatever your innovation is
and you can't rely on them as much as
you think you can the other thing that
you just sparked is
a couple months ago the economist asked
me to write a piece on
how bosses and and companies are going
to evolve post-pandemic
and my first reaction is this is just a
fool's errand right
what's the old saying that historians
can't even predict the past with perfect
accuracy
the future is not going to work so well
but i thought maybe what i can do is i
can go to research on other crises and
recessions
and try to figure out what's the you
know the imprint that that creates
and there's this amazing work by emily
bianchi where she shows that the the
state of the economy
when you graduate from college cast a
shadow on the next couple decades of
your career
and so for example if you graduate from
college during a recession you're
significantly happier with your job a
decade or so later
because you're grateful to have a job
and the most i think uplifting part of
her research is that if you graduate
from college and start your career
during a recession
if you become a ceo a couple decades
later you actually pay your employees
more generously
because you know what it's like to be at
the bottom and struggle and so i wonder
to your point
if the next generation of leaders is
going to experience a real sense of no
blessed
ah wonderful and remember the current
generation of leaders we have right now
come out of the 80s and 90s which are
these boom years
you know greed is good gordon gekko
stock market ridiculousness
you know that makes a lot of sense that
makes a lot of sense you might have just
connected those dots to make a case for
optimism
very interesting you and i cannot have a
discussion without us
at least talking about the concept of
worthy rivalry
because i wrote about you in infinite
game when i used you as the
primary example in this discussion of
what a worthy rival is
and the way i defined a worthy rival was
where you have a competitor
in a finite game which is a competitor
to be beaten if there's a winner there
has to be a loser
but in the infinite game we don't have
competitors we have rivals and some of
those rivals are worthy of comparison
and the way i define a worthy rival is
they do some or a lot of things better
than you
and their strengths reveal to you your
weaknesses
and when that happens very often the
human response is insecurity
or a heightened competitiveness i'm
going to beat them
right because it's born out of
insecurity and that is
my relationship with you for many many
years
you know i would log on to amazon to
check my book rankings
and i would immediately check yours i
would check no one else's
even though there's lots of books in our
category i would only check yours
and if you were ahead i'd be like that
adam grant and if i was a head i'd be
like uh-huh uh-huh there you go
and you and i knew each other and we
would see each other professionally we
were always cordial to each other you're
always very nice to me
and it was when you and i were
interviewed together at the aspen
institute
that we were asked to introduce each
other
and i remember i turned to you
and i said you make me really insecure
i said all of your strengths are all of
my weaknesses
and when your name comes up i get
uncomfortable
and you said something to the effect of
funny i feel the same about you
and it was this incredibly cathartic
moment that i realized the
competitiveness that i had with you
had nothing to do with you it had
everything to do with me okay so we we
have a lot to talk about here so
let me um let me let me let me rewind to
the beginning of your story
so i think i must have watched your ted
talk in the first year that it came out
because my students would always tell me
about the you know about what they were
watching and i
barely heard a ted at that point i was
like i wish i could speak like that
like it's just there's charisma oozing
through the screen i didn't even know
that was possible
and i i remember thinking you know maybe
maybe one day uh if i ever get invited
to the ted stage
i will be a fraction that engaging and
dynamic but
only a fraction and that was kind of
annoying
and then i sort of forgot about it
in large part because like you know i
was hiding in the ivory tower as an
academic
and it didn't even occur to me to
compare myself to people who were
writing books and giving ted talks right
because i didn't belong
in that category and so i didn't know
that we had a rivalry
other than having been insecure by the
way a rivalry doesn't
and the competition both parties know
and her rivalries sometimes the other
party has no clue
there is yeah okay so maybe we had an
asymmetric rival yeah but
you were mind-worthy rival i wasn't
necessarily yours well there were i mean
there were just so many candidates right
like i could make a list of
of all the authors and speakers i
admired and it's like why would i just
compare myself to one
and then something really funny happened
which is a few months before
that aspen event two of our mutual
friends independently told me
you know your name came up in a
conversation with simon sinek i was like
oh
i flattered that anyone was talking
about me why and
both of them had different versions of
you know like simon really enjoys
competing with you and i was like i have
no idea this is news to me and so i
thought
you know what this is so interesting
like we are so lucky to be in a
profession where neither of us has to
worry
that this is zero sum by the way for the
record i didn't enjoy it
okay well that that's good to know
i just thought like what what what if we
got together and talked about this
so we had this aspen thing coming up and
uh i was like
okay i'm supposed to talk to katie kirk
what if simon joined us i bet we could
have an even more interesting
conversation
and i don't think you gave yourself
enough credit because i remember we were
sitting
um we just walked up and katie said
what do you guys want to do i'm here
like let me know and you said
i think we should introduce each other
and had you not done that i'm not sure
that either of us
would have spoken about this feeling of
mutual insecurity
so i i thought that was a it was a
courageous and vulnerable move that you
made and
it completely the moment you said like
well you you know your strengths are my
weaknesses i was like
hello pot i am kettle and this is what
exactly what happened which is we are
not competitors
you know i don't consider us competitors
and it turns out because it's not zero
sum
because putting good ideas out into the
world and your your ideas and my ideas
are so complimentary in so many ways
yeah you know it's one of the reasons i
enjoy your work so much ditto
you add a depth and robustness to my
work and this is what i admire about you
so much which is your ability
to not only read all these studies
but to remember them and track them and
add the credibility
because i may have a crazy observation
or a theory and you'll say
ah let me give you some data on that and
it's this yin and yang that i love
and where before i viewed you as a
worthy rival
now i view you as a friend and
compatriot wait are we friends
when did that happen yeah well just 20
minutes ago and for the record
for the record no longer compare our
book rankings and never have since that
aspen
discussion wow ended that day
because it was this recognition that it
was entirely my insecurity
and had nothing to do with you so me
looking at these arbitrary rank because
book sales
is it's a metric it's an arbitrary
metric and
all it was doing is is feeding the
insecurity
it was feeding a competitiveness because
at the end of the day it was irrelevant
because the only thing i had to compete
against was myself i had to make my work
better than my work not my work better
than anybody else's work
yeah and to be out loud about it was
cathartic
and i've had a much healthier attitude
towards all those kinds of relationships
where ever since that day i have no
competitors other than myself
and yet i admire some people's work and
some people's work i don't admire
and the people's work i admire i can
either partner with them work with them
or i can use them as a pacer to push me
to work harder
wow well i was going to say i was
honored to be your worthy rival but i
guess i
no longer deserve that honor so we'll
take that off the table
your strengths still reveal to me my
weaknesses don't you worry
same no no and and simon so i i i have
to say that
it's amazing it's almost like we're a
whole person if you combine both of our
work
because i feel like every time i read
something you write or
i i see you give a speech or we end up
chatting informally
you push me to ask bolder questions and
you think about things that
i would just never even it wouldn't even
occur to me right i think you're
you're a much more original thinker than
i am and you also like you have that
ability to
turn your ideas into stories that people
never forget
and i i desperately need more of both of
those things and so i think that's
that's awesome i do wonder if there's
something lost by not having a worthy
rival and if there's
you know if there's something you're
missing by only competing with yourself
and the reason i ask in part
oh no no no worthy rivals are are
absolutely essential
i have plenty of worthy rivals and you
are absolutely still one of them okay
good
the point is to make that mindset
conversion that these are not
competitors to be beaten but their mere
existence
reveals to your weaknesses which means
that's how you can become a better
player now worthy rivals
are absolutely essential to the growth
of ourselves and the growth of our work
great okay that was exactly where i was
going because i was i was thinking about
this episode of my ted podcast work life
that i
had done where you had a cameo where you
know we we had that back and forth about
you know
sort of being being insecure around each
other and i was so impressed by the
evidence showing that people actually
perform better
when they're competing against a worthy
rival and
i like your frame shift to say look you
know just just because
i've got somebody in mind who's better
than me at certain things does not mean
i have to
beat them what i want to do is learn
from them correct and
these are people who raised the bar for
me and the the instruction i always give
is you don't have to like them
and you don't have to agree with them
but you do have to respect them
because their work is good work or they
do something better than you
and that's respectable that's a great
example of a simon cynic mic drop right
there
right like i would love to be able to
produce that sentence
in real time i i'm gonna have to sit
down and
write various drafts of it for two hours
and then market test it on twitter to
see if people think it's dumb or
insightful
and then the mic will drop but
no i mean this like this this wisdom on
demand skill is something that
i would actually like to study and
figure out is that teachable
well uh you can hook me up to electrodes
if you need to
sadly i'm not that kind of social
scientist but i i have friends who are
as do you
i do so enjoy talking to you we really
should do it more often
this has been a long time coming adam's
such a joy
please be well take care of yourself
likewise simon this was uh this was fun
thanks for the invite
my pleasure good to talk to you
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other